okay guys so every day I change my mind
about what city I want to go to so I'm
going to interview my producer about
where we should
move also so what do you think of Vegas
Vegas is so much space mhm it's cheap
out there in
Vegas um the people seem
nice the ones we met anyways I head is
crazy as well
so Mak good entertainment yeah yeah and
the weather is not so so
extreme like I feel like Vegas is hot
there's dust everywhere though it wasn't
as crazy as my app oh it's hot you think
it's hotter here yeah yeah probably so
what do you think of
Miami Miami is a Vibe I think equally
you get crazy people here because they
eat they just drive people crazy well I
was thinking too Miami would be good
because
there's so many um people that like live
out like YouTubers and like not even
like from panel perspective cuz I think
we're kind of going away from that but
like um interviews yeah interviews yeah
like I think Miami would be a little
better than Vegas in that point of view
probably yeah and it's more so far out I
feel like Vegas I love people have
trouble up there like it's far
yeah okay what about
Chicago I had this cold haven't been
there in the cold season okay but we
have such a good but like we have
everything at the compound yeah but
access to it seems like it's a bit
trickier like we have to get people all
the way out
there seem like it's more easy you know
what I mean it would but I I don't know
Chicago is in the middle of the country
but yeah I mean you're right but I just
love that compound that compound's
amazing compound is amazing yeah it's
amazing and then my dad's pretty cool
too so like BR on I I think the compound
will work if we do like some annual
stuff annual stuff yeah say like annual
competitions if it's like red pool
content or annual whatever consen or
something like
that but for for daily content I don't
know okay well guys this is what we're
thinking stop asking me when I'm moving
I don't know
I am I am we just you know slow and
steady wins wins the race guys so you
know let me know what you think in the
comments like it subscribe yeah